sebastian lege hat da mal wieder was
gebastelt
dafür braucht er hilfe von der feuerwehr
und das alles für den supermarkt
knallhart tütensuppen mit diesem pulver
habe ich ihnen jede suppe und soße diese
wollen was dieses weiße pulver in
unseren tütensuppen sucht und was das
ganze mit kartoffeln zu tun hat schauen
wir uns mal an
[Musik]
suppen und saucen aus der tüte gibt es
im supermarkt wie sand am meer und
überall ist es drin das wunder pulver
der lebensmittelindustrie
das sorgt in nullkommanix für himmlische
cremigkeit bei jeder suppe und soße es
sparte industrie außerdem teure zutaten
und ist geschmacksneutral
ich kann hier alle in einen topf werfen
weil es überall das gleiche drin das
zauber pulver will sebastian auch und er
trägt der industrie ist einfacher als
gedacht denn bei dem pulver handelt es
sich um kartoffelstärke dafür braucht
sebastian klar kartoffeln genauer den
saft da steckt die beliebte stärke
bringen
aber so ist das ganze noch viel zu
flüssig
[Gelächter]
um daraus ein feines pulver zu machen
kommt sebastian selbstgebaute
höllenmaschine zum einsatz
eine trocken trommel abgeht
und zwar so auf der inneren der zwei
trommeln wird er stärker saft
aufgetragen
mit ordentliches von außen geht's jetzt
rund jetzt muss es richtig schon
getrocknet werden weil wir wollen ja
schnee weißes pulver erhalten ansonsten
würde es verbrennen sebastians
meisterwerk funktioniert genauso wie die
großen industriemaschinen das wasser
verdunstet es bleibt feinster stärke
stau löst sie richtig feines pulver von
meiner träume
so soll sein das wunder pulver kann
jetzt quasi überall eingesetzt werden
gemischt mit wasser quillt die
kartoffelstärke auf und eine sämige
konsistenz entsteht die perfekte
grundlage für fertigprodukte aus der
tüte sebastian zeigt uns die magie der
kartoffelstärke etwas spargel aroma zum
pulver schnittlauch fürs auge ein hauch
getrockneter spargel und tada fertig ist
unser instant spargelsuppe cocktail aus
kartoffelstärke schmeckt lecker nach
spargelsuppe aber in dieser suppe der
gerade mal so viel spargel dank des
pärchens sparen hersteller bei teuren
zutaten spargelsuppe mit nur vier
prozent spargel kein problem
teure sahne überflüssig tatsächlich ist
die kartoffelstärke sogar hauptzutat
übrigens das ganze klappt auch
hervorragend mit bratensoße hauptzutat
auch hier die magische kartoffelstärke
bei bratensauce sollte man außerdem auf
die bezeichnung arten soße zu braten und
bratensoße klingt fast gleich doch der
wesentliche unterschied nur die
bratensoße enthält auch wirklich fleisch
extrakte in der soße zu braten hingegen
stecken nur aromen
es raschelt also bei suppen und saucen
aus der tüte
das nächste mal checken wie viel echte
zutaten und wieviel kartoffelstärke drin
ist nachschlag gefällig auf unserem
kanal zdf besser esser gibt's noch mehr
tricks checks und duelle aus der welt
der lebensmittel